this white blanket and darling river is
made up of millions of dead fish
the rotting remains of mainly bream
cotton perch are clogging Australia's
second longest river
and they're disrupting the lives of
people in the small town of men indeed
so you're walking around in a dried up
mess and then you're smelling this
putrid smell and
it's it's a terrible smell and a
horrible to see all those dead fish
local authorities say unusually hot
weather has led to a large algal bloom
in the rivers this coupled with receding
flood waters and drying riverbeds have
starved fish of oxygen in a statement
the New South Wales State Department
says the hot weather is exacerbating
hypoxia as warmer water holds less
oxygen than cold water the fish have
higher oxygen needs at warmer
temperatures
this is the third Mass die off of fish
in the darling River in 2019 nearly 1
million fish perished there but the New
South Wales Department of primary
Industries says the latest is the worst
with hardly any fish being Left Alive
it's just that feeling of hopelessness
that no one wants to take any
responsibility for it and really all we
want is to maintain a healthy River
authorities say fish populations usually
boom during the floods and then fall as
flood waters recede the local people
blame poor water management they say
more needs to be done to improve the
drainage and quality of water to prevent
another wall of dead fish loracan Al
Jazeera